Abby Lee Miller undergoes emergency  surgery to save her life  I'm scared I'm nervous  et can confirm the 51 year old Dance  Moms star is currently recovering  following an unscheduled 5-hour surgery  that happened early Tuesday morning to  remove an infected mass that was putting  pressure on her spine  Abby's orthopedic spine surgeon dr.  Holman Malamud  tells ET she could have died the reality  star was experiencing extreme pain in  her back neck and arms before hooman  discovered the mass in a CT scan and  rushed Abby into emergency surgery  quotes Abby was paralyzed yesterday and  could not move forget paralysis if she  waited much longer she would have died  from this Abby couldn't move her toes or  hands now she can slightly but Abby  isn't out of the woods just yet the  doctor says the cause of the infection  is still unknown and she may need  surgery in the future you know I don't  know what the future holds